all right let's get right into our
Friday mailbag the Friday mailbag I have
to say on average has been improving in
quality with occasional really horrible
emails but you can email info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say uh sometimes people will ask for
Corrections in the Friday mailbag if
they are appropriate I'm glad to give
them we don't hide the corrections you
know on the last page of the paper or
anything like that we put them at the
top of the mailbag when appropriate okay
let's start first email is from Bob this
is kind of interesting Bob sends some
questions for the future
and says hey David I'm from the year
3328 I was watching your show in the
historical archives and found it
insightful I was hoping you could give
me perspective on issues people are
dealing with today one do you think
clone marriage should be legal now see I
don't even understand that do you mean
clones of the same person marrying each
other or just clones in general getting
married
but probably yeah I mean I don't know
they're different people sure number two
should genetic engineering be guaranteed
coverage by health insurance probably I
Believe by 3328 there at least will be
insurance for that three are alien
species fit to serve in Earth politics
if they are legal citizens 100 I believe
if you are a naturalized Earthling uh
even if you come from a different planet
and listen if you speak the language if
you understand our system if you share
our values who do I sound like uh now I
I don't know on Aliens
um from other planets being being
politicians should AI be able to vote I
think no on that
and number five is debris pollution from
asteroid gov mining something the
government should try to regulate in the
wake of the recent Mars freighter
disaster I would say yes sir I think I
would be very much able to make
decisions about
30th year 33-28 uh World governance I
like that Bob really giving giving us
something to think about there let's go
next to Michael writing in about Alex
Jones
Michael says David do you think Alex
Jones is now a suicide risk if so is he
likely to take others with him I think
he should be carefully watched when you
consider his obsession with Firearms his
pathological anger and the impossibility
of ever recovering from the verdict
against him I believe he has been backed
into a corner his agenda has been chaos
and destruction from the beginning and
now he will take it to the Limit I fear
I would not be surprised to hear of his
committing a mass murder suicide I hope
there are people around him who can
prevent this
um I wonder the same of trump if
DeSantis wins the primary no so so the
there there are good questions here
I don't think Trump is liable to do
self-harm if DeSantis defeats him in the
primary I don't
I do see Alex Jones as a possible
self-harm risk I don't get the sense of
Alex Jones necessarily taking others
down with him
I know that many of you might be
surprised and say his rhetoric about
others is really wacky Maybe I'm Wrong I
see Alex Jones primarily physically
speaking as a risk to himself
next to email is from Alan Allen argues
in response to what I asked last week
are trumpists too far gone
Allen says Trump supporters are not too
far gone and writes David sir you
recently asked on your show if Trump
supporters are too far gone if they
could be put in the right environment I
say no however many Trump supporters
only consume TV programs that reinforce
their positions or are being funneled
into extremist media in their social
media by AI TV hosts and social media
companies are making tons of money off
of all this and it will not stop without
some kind of legislation
the legislation is not coming because
these people are voting in more extreme
politicians who either have the same
goals or also profit I have lost a
friend but she was not lost to Trump At
first she was funneled into Q Anon by
Twitter if I ever get the motivation
I'll send some old chat threads they are
insane I do agree with one aspect of
this which is I do think a complete
environmental shift for these trumpists
would have an impact because we have a
study that says that I don't know if it
was like nine months or maybe a year or
18 months ago we had a study that
measured the effect what happens if you
take trumpists or I think it was like
Fox News viewers people who primarily or
exclusively get their news from Fox
you take them out of that and you give
them a month of something different and
they tested a few different something
difference and their views did begin to
change but it required getting off of
the Fox News so
I I agree with Alan very difficult to
make that happen Carl wrote in with one
of the many Corrections about my
interview with my pillow CEO Mike
Lindell as I told you all it's really
hard to correct everything when someone
tells hundreds of Lies during an
interview one of the things pillow
claimed was that all the 2020 election
lawsuits that were thrown out were
thrown out for standing and not on the
merits it turns out that's not true Carl
wrote to me about it and said please pin
Mike Lindell down next time on the 60
election suits issue most were dismissed
for lack of evidence not the right-wing
claim repeated a trillion times that
they were all dismissed for lack of
standing
this is an easy one with court document
proof yes great information if he's back
on or if someone else tries that talking
point on me I will be prepared it can be
really difficult to prepare for every
talking point and I didn't have examples
specific examples in front of me
Brewster also wrote in about the
interview with Mike pillow says David
I'm a big fan and I count on you to
provide me the latest and most accurate
news however I do have some criticism
about your interview with Mike it was
unnecessary for you to correct Mike's
mispronunciations it made you look like
you were trying to demonstrate how much
more educated you are than him there
were far more important topics to cover
so the only correction I made was that
he pronounced Kamala Harris's name
incorrectly
and for me that's not about education
right Wingers
don't even respect her enough
to learn how her name is said I believe
there is much more to the constant
mispronunciation of Kamala Harris's name
for these right Wingers why do the
left-wingers it's not education why do
the left-waners know how to pronounce it
and the right Wingers don't I believe
there is a xenophobic racist component
to it and it's a an inter I mean listen
guys it's when I jokingly say tool C
gabbard right
what am I doing when I do that we all
know what I'm doing okay I'm doing it on
purpose with them I don't know if they
just don't actually respect the person
enough to know what they're naming I
know it's not Dan bongino it's Dan
bongino
all right
uh next email is from James would the
Army using electric vehicles convince
right-wingers to go electric another
left Progressive YouTuber brought up
that the Department of Defense is
looking for a new light Recon vehicle
and intended intend on that being an
electric vehicle the current proposal is
a militarized version of General Motors
Hummer electric vehicle he thinks this
will be what pushes the anti-electric
vehicle right into embracing AVS because
that crowd has a strong pull towards
trying to imitate the military I'm not
so sure that the rights desire for
tactical is strong enough to wipe out
wipe out the stupid impression that EVS
will somehow emasculate them yeah I
agree if the military became known for
really rugged electric vehicles
I do believe that that would push a
bunch of right-wingers to at least be
open to electric vehicles the electric
F-150 has made significant inroads I
don't know the status of the electric
Hummer but sounds like that maybe that
would as well but there is going to be
it it's going to be sort of a stubborn
belief that electric vehicles are
terrible and bad and feminine and all
this stuff for a while but I think if
the Army started using EVS it would make
a difference Chris asks a good question
who is they asks Chris uh David love
your show have a question who is they
why is it that the right always says
they are taking your rights they don't
want you to know they hate America for a
group that hates pronouns it is odd how
they lean on the mysterious they so much
in responding to legitimate questions
don't you think keep up the good work
yeah I mean listen
they is a catch-all for some combination
of Democrats marxists socialists
Communists wokists antifa BLM sometimes
Jews if it's inconvenient sometimes
minorities sometimes they can be
anything they can be whatever best fits
the story so if they go
they're holding you down they're not
letting you live the life you want to
live could be anybody and depending on
whether the story is about the US
government or some shadowy Elite cabal
or who knows it's just to fill in the
blank and they'll just go through it and
try try again until they get something
that fits I now I have to say
sometimes the word they does come
naturally once you've already made clear
who you're talking about so sometimes
I'll say
in a story I'll open it by saying the uh
most religious element of the American
right wing has decided that they are
going to vote on an election and
election only and then I'll say more
stuff and then later I'll say they
I'm referring back to that same very
most religious element of the American
right wing I try to remind myself I
should try to restate who it is I'm
talking about
to avoid falling into this they thing so
Chris's email is a good reminder
wrote in about voter fraud I actually
can't tell if this is for Real
Busta says how could you possibly do
that long of a response video about what
would convince you that there was voter
fraud and not talk about 2 000 mules the
movie was cheesy with its use of dark
rooms and drama but the evidence was
extremely compelling two thousand mules
is exactly the voter fraud evidence you
said you would accept I don't know if
this person is for real or not 2 000
mules was a joke we've already gone
through this multiple times two thousand
mules is based on very specious
geolocation data of mobile phones that
they have not even actually connected to
voting related activities it is
completely speculative it doesn't
actually show anything other than
supposedly certain people with mobile
phones were grouped in different areas
that they claim are suspicious close to
ballot drop boxes
that's all they have
I'm simplifying a little bit it was not
compelling
it was not compelling and if someone
thinks that 2 000 meals is proof of
anything other than Dinesh de sues as
delusion and narcissism
then I don't know that we have much to
talk about
we have a great bonus show for you today
don't miss the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah especially in
this era of Alex Jones hating the bonus
show thank your lucky stars every day
you're not Dave Pacman well all right
that Alex thank you very much uh it is a
great time to sign up at joinpakman.com
joinpakman.com coupon code big voting 22
just a couple weeks left before the big
voting day hope you'll sign up and I'll
see you on the bonus show